you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing any
five-oh game all right let's go with the
Carol Penn advance okay
G for or not on g4 I could go all the
way back I could also consider Bishop
efore and g6 then once caked with f3
however I have to always be a bit
careful v6 if I want to come out for
this diagonal prior to getting this move
in are they disconnected or something
okay
so it's a big moment do I go in for
Bishop b4 f3 Bishop g6e 6 takes Knight
d7 and then I still may be pushed
through I'm going to give that a shot
this is a pretty committal line I'm
going to go east 6 I'm going to allow
them to do that no playing h4 first Wow
okay let's meet that one h5 I could have
some serious difficulty getting my
Bishop out I'm expecting e6 maybe Knight
h3 or e2 and to f4 to rattle my bishop
but let's see on e6 I could actually
consider taking and then playing Knight
f6 as if the pawn isn't even there we'll
see
ok they're going straight in for Knight
f4 alright I'm going to take bits up
recapture I was expecting night of four
first isn't this allowing a nice strike
at the h4 pawn let's see not necessarily
threatening my bishop if they play h5
right here I think I have to play h5
rook takes h4 meanwhile I'll be looking
to play see 6 9 c6 I think straight away
seem sensible I like the fact that on
Knight f4 I get play Bishop e4 get out
of the line of fire now I don't think I
want to go straight in for that I think
I could do this on takes bishop I take
the rook mm actually Bishop g2 is a bit
of a bug isn't it that stops Bishop here
and threatens bishop on takes bishop
oh that's another move that does that
the rook is defended now nOCA I guess
I'm going to drop back this would be
very critical line yeah going straight
in for that
yikes okay noted what to do with my
bishop hmm or actually don't even have
to do anything just yet hmm I'm going to
try this move meeting g6 with Bishop to
here this could be the wrong idea this
would be five I'm not scared of get this
Knight here
very aggressive play so far by team
white so I'm threatening this pawn now
all right that one wasn't scaring me so
much is it's going to be concern I'm
going to find out hmm they take straight
away okay hmm
about g6 preparing to throw my knight in
to f5 probably Bishop g5 will be hitting
and if I'm not careful Queen f3 is
hitting soon maybe I go direct here with
Queen b6 hmm preparing the Castle
queenside but not just yet
I'll actually clean off three straight
away is tough oh boy
I may have to try Queen d7 and then
Knight here that's awkward as well hmm
yeah this is tough I was preparing to
meet something like Queen a through
Bishop GA hmm
I mean I may need to give up some
material here this is an attempt to try
and release some pressure on the F file
I guess I would have to recapture right
if they do some kind of sack on f7 not
very fun to do this two very valuable
pieces in the line of fire Bishop g5 is
a bit annoying okay let's start with
this and then I could think about
castling castling straight away would
have dropped the bishop there King is
pretty naked though so if I could kind
of survive here even if I'm down some
material if I could get my king tucked
away be satisfied I think we'll see Wow
you pawn grab are you all right
well I think I'm getting away
King safety wise the Queen's are still
on the board opposite sides castling I
shouldn't be too concerned about
material loss I don't think at least
Bishop here mm-hmm
or just move my rook gotta make a move
yeah Bishop e7 I didn't think rook move
was any good
my rooks are connected now preparing to
meet multiple captures here with Bishop
e6 and I could still do that can I not
and I got to take with the pawn now okay
a bit uncomfortable
take care oh wow really lining up with
some rook takes Knight well I got to
recapture like this down to a minute now
they're going with this okay so Bishop
block they still have a some work to do
right with the Queen side now I'm ready
to roll here getting my rooks activated
Queen here stuff or even here no what's
wrong with that
we're gonna have to show me I want to
release the pressure this queen is just
too much huh
this is a problem for them no he's
running for the hills
hmm 45 seconds let's start with this
let's take there and I think I'm just
going to go straight down give a check
and then try to work on the pin tonight
is there something better I'm going to
start with that and let's find a safe
square let's go here the Queen attacks
the rip I have Queen g5 this rook is
restricting to pieces let's keep it shut
down here comes the Queen Queen f1
común exchange I could do this because I
have bishop here
and now the clock the tricky clock and
here for starters rook exchange is what
I want I'm okay with giving up some on
this is winning just stop any trickery
over here and push these pawns to
Victory Lane
alright where's the mate right around
the corner it's gonna do it who I don't
know I don't know to say I'll say good
game yeah I don't know I thought I was
busted with the aggressive play on the
Kings side but hmm it's a very sharp
line I felt like I was just on the ropes
for so many moves but yeah as mentioned
opposite sides counseling material not
so much of an issue of really came down
to King safety in the end that's not how
the evaluation on just yet I believe
okay I have to hit that so it's going to
do any a quick analysis here but while
it's doing that let me just point out
that I was almost always in the habit
playing on the black side here with this
advanced variation to meet g4 with
keeping my maintaining my bishop on this
diagonal and the reason for this is
because this is a move that I feared but
I looked into it a little bit more and I
believe black kind of just gives the
pawn back you know having these double
pawns
makes life very difficult especially for
the bishop on f8 but I believe there's a
way to just play Knight d7 and push
through just kind of a give the pawn
back something like this maybe even
Bishop here first
but I don't know something like that
where you just quickly get give the pawn
back in order to open up the bishop it's
not the only way to play it I don't have
so much experience with that but I
normally kind of just come all the way
back here and I'm content with actually
hemming my bishop in
item I pawn chain playing e6 and then
looking to strike at the tail and kind
of reason that hey this g4 move yeah
that's pretty committal you know it
doesn't get any more weakening than that
and the White King really would never
find comfort over here on the Kings side
meanwhile this is the direction I would
be going in east 6 first then c5 Knight
c6 striking out this a target on d4
putting pressure there anyhow that's not
what happened in the game I just wanted
to touch on a different of a couple
different ideas that the Bishop has once
questioned with g4 I'm opting for Bishop
b4 a lot of pawn moves Knight f4 I
thought straight away yeah I don't know
I thought I was going to be crunched
here maybe maybe c5 was too early but my
if I did this I figured I don't know
like the rook steps up
maybe here has a lot of lateral
influence and soon them you know having
to work with developing move with tempo
I don't know felt a little odd in the
end I just got on with striking at the
tail 96 hits the bishop the problem here
is that I can't take well actually I
could take like this I can't take with
the bishop but I could take with the
knight
hmm I didn't consider that it looks it
looks very uncomfortable for me though
yeah I don't know about opening up the
h-file completely for a white like that
I take maybe that's something better
than taking here I don't know yeah I'm
down upon but again there wasn't uh I'm
still getting some development in with
these moves we'll see what kind of
tactics were missed
and probably some some stuff was missed
I'm almost certain I'm winning here I'm
just looking at the notation now on the
right hand side was the evaluation Singh
okay okay that's a bit reassuring huh I
guess I didn't miss anything aside from
the typical opening advantage with white
having some space with e5 yeah I guess I
didn't miss anything
that does that's not to say that there
isn't some improvement but let's see
let's put the arrows on and we'll keep
an eye on this evaluation now see how
white could have maybe done one better
h4 hmm f3
there let me just let me just look at
this takes h4 Queen c7 yeah the name is
name of the game from here is to make
the moves that are going to help
facilitate an e5 advance so why we saw
Queen c7 and now Knights eat Knight to
d7 popping up
okay and also even this moment here
after g4 if I go straight back now it's
worthwhile if you're going to stay on
this diagonal it's worthwhile to provoke
f3 because this isn't a help helpful
move just interferes with the Queen
fears with the Knight makes the King
more vulnerable should he go Kings side
yeah so if you're going to stand this
dog and it's best to go to e4 before you
go straight into g6 so here here and
suppose e6 yeah we're just taking and
then trying to get into e5 advance the
other variation I was pointing out was
Bishop here what's the evaluation
looking like it's much more solid
approach of course you're not allowing
this dent to be placed into the black
structure and yeah you don't have to
worry about your bishop getting trapped
over here with some pawn storm Bishop
their Queen b6 or eise Ickx yeah III
like this I mean I could have very well
gone in for this kind of thing where I
just retreated and said hey you know
that's a pretty committal move but I
chose a more committal Road or a dynamic
Road I guess we could say takes I
thought Knight f4 would have been better
and I have been
this takes and then Bishop efore rook h3
stuff on h4 there hmm and black white
has their own worries as well here with
h4 right and that was that was felt in
the game at least for one moment I was
throwing a punch there so they didn't
cost rating for Knight f4 they take push
I could go and Bishop b4 now that's what
it's suggesting but c5 isn't bad i
backup g5 I played 97 all right well
done all right I played Bishop g8 and
that was my instinct capturing yeah it's
no good you don't really have to
calculate you just you just know if
you're going to open up this position
just like I eventually did when I had my
rook on the first rank one piece
restricting too you know that's kind of
the situation I'm in my row can't move
and my bishop well he can move actually
because they're nice defending the rook
but yeah really asking for some trouble
to bring the white pieces to life like
this even if it's just even if it's just
one piece so I have to do this as
awkward as it looks I'm really backed up
but they are quite uh extended these are
not developing those that's another way
to look at it they are kicking me around
some but no new pieces are entering the
scene check their check their castles
yeah I think this is maybe one of the
moves I spent the most time with Queen
d7 I guess I could jump straight in now
five I didn't want to do my initial
thought was to do this to to really
focus on f5 and in doing so I'm
sheltering the rooks influence on these
three squares if I could establish a
piece on the f5 square but my concern is
exactly what the computer suggesting
here where the bishop can develop and
immediately observe the two weaknesses
now that I created with
that move both h6 and f6 are holes in
them in a pin apparently it is still
okay but I thought these were I guess
unnecessary weaknesses to make therefore
Queen d7 Knight f5 okay I guess it likes
how I played it I didn't even consider I
could take the night huh oh wow
okay the queenside castling is alright
but I didn't even consider this I was
completely blind to taking the night ah
this seemed this was a lot simpler than
huh because I don't have a messed up
structure at all I'm not going to be
down upon and in fact I'll be picking up
the h-bond it seems Knight takes Queen
takes
I don't think there's any issue with
taking that pond right away however he's
hit twice defended zero I probably no
rush what's taking him
what's wrong with queenside castle
nothing
bishop here rook over and he soon to
fall opposite color bishops yeah this is
this is looking good for black okay I
should have at least seen that I could
take the night didn't even cross my mind
I guess nothing was missed as we saw
with the graph hmm yeah they're up upon
but look at that evaluation what's more
important here development in cases
where it's opposite sides counseling ok
h6 it takes phone threatening Rick g5
and it's busted here
I guess there's many different ways you
could win it I just wanted to be assured
that they would have to spend forever to
get out of that pin I don't know if I
set it in the video but I didn't want to
go here because there's a queen move
here like I just kind of reasoned let's
put the rook on a light square that way
if he's struck out along a diagonal
maybe my queen could enter here but
that's not this yeah that is true the
Queen can't go here hit the rook and
defend Queen g5 because of the bishop
and if she goes here well enters the
Queen and it's already calling for me in
7 yeah hmm so what more to say yeah this
is just winning this ending
there's no fancy pawn moves or anything
that I could come up with to create a
passed pawn or anything so this is like
an opening it's got to be some
improvement here in the opening for
white h4 right there Knight f4 hmm is
that really the main
provement no not necessarily I guess
right here it's still it's still a tough
call point for if it should be 5 yeah
that that really didn't scare me so much
in the game night c3 instead getting
some some new piece into the mix and I
get to take the Queen takes I get some
development now that's you know probably
a position where you have to give the
computer some time to think this one
through but yeah it's a committal
decision for sure you know I'm not with
these pawns coming down like this it's
not like I'm going all-in or I haven't
committed my King just yet on the Kings
side so if I could get the moves in
clear my queen side out throw my King
over here and then the big question is
where is he going to live well
game for sure surprising a graph to see
their I was not expecting that and you
know know what more to really add it's
complicated a complicated game okay
well as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video leave any
comments in the comment section below
and as usual I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you